i'm sorry ma'am we've locked up your
spam
thank you for that laugh
yes thanks to inflation and crime buying
your favorite pork is no easy time
well just like me when i was a child
four dollar cans of spam are now being
locked inside a plastic anti-theft case
and it's not just spam new york city
stores are locking up basic stuff like
toothpaste and soap to keep it from
crooks who swipe it and then sell it
elsewhere seriously i just bought a
water pick in washington square park
don't worry it's not for my teeth
what do you mean
a spokeswoman says installing anti-theft
devices is in response to theft data
which is transmitted straight from cat's
ankle monitor
so it's the perfect symbol of the biden
era
preservative-packed mystery meat kept
tight under glass
which i wonder which one has a longer
shelf life
but this is what you get when the
highest inflation in decades meets the
rising crime wave thanks to policies
that don't punish repeat offenders like
michelle mckelley a serial shoplifter
who was previously arrested a hundred
times and repeatedly released without
bail she's finally landed in jail but
only because she fought with cops
kicking biting and spitting at them
after her latest arrest reminds me of
dana's performance review
although it wasn't spam she swiped it
was paper towels
apparently they bring in quite a bounty
luckily one of the officers who subdued
her was described as brawny
sorry about the paper towel puns guess
you could say i'm on a roll
anyway bail was set at five grand or two
cases of spam
but it got me thinking about a skit
about spam
thank you all for coming i'm sheriff
randy biscuits as you know law
enforcement is working overtime to keep
our streets clean of the most dangerous
things known to man
fentanyl crystal meth
and jim acosta that's why i'd like to
share with you our biggest bust to date
any questions
yeah sheriff how much are we talking as
far as street value here
uh yeah this right here this spam is
worth approximately 350 million dollars
uh yeah sure what's that other pile over
there oh that's just cocaine y'all can
bid on that at the next police auction
roscoe no
that's that's all for today thank you
roscoe's got a thing with coke come on
roscoe let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
jagan
people laugh at spam but it's well
you're oh wait you're the you're a vegan
when was the last time you had spam um
well you have your kind of p pick um
spam there's treat me which is a spam
rival
there is potted meat yes and they're uh
vienna sausages yes would you remember
this did you remember the um the deviled
ham that were coming around a little bit
yeah like
you know it's been decades but i can
still taste it in my mouth
um i don't think people are stealing the
spam no to eat it or resell it i it's a
pretty damn good weapon yeah you know
the second amendment doesn't exist here
in new york city that can container if
you if you've got good aim you can break
somebody's nose with that son of a [ __ ]
yeah also if you if you you know if you
open it you kind of and you do the the
the
the top itself is a
yeah
i don't even know what i was doing there
corey
but um isn't it kind of a weird i guess
metaphor
spam under glass is is this country
right now you know it's just sad
well i mean again this just goes to show
i mean these democrat-controlled cities
that are absolutely pro-crime you know
this catch and release this i can do
anything and get out on bail i mean i
stopped shaving when they put the razors
in the actual plastic box so i don't
know what i'm going to do now with spam
but you know it's true i mean you look
at what's going on you have people who
are violating other officers in the
subways and they're being turned around
and released on bail at no cost i mean
this whole soft on crime policy this
catch and release ideology is exactly
what's wrong and this increased
criminality is to terrorize individual
cities and it's being done only in
democrat run areas yeah it's interesting
it's like they we're watching the broken
windows policy actually happening and
you can only notice that if you remove
the broken windows policy that if you
just let smaller infractions go they
just get bigger and bigger over time and
then you have spam under glass cat
i think it's unfair and i think you
might agree with me that we call stuff
that we get in our email
stuff that we don't like spam
why why would we where did that come
from how did that evolve have you ever
thought about that no i forgot to do an
etymology report on that
get something to me tonight
just
absolutely after the show absolutely i
have nothing going on
in the world to do that i i don't
understand why they put in plastic
though i truly don't because i don't
think
if you're in a place in your life
where you're stealing spam
i don't think you're gonna get in there
and be like well no i can't take it like
you just
you just pick it up and you can remove
that later but no i think i think the
box is held in and i think what they do
is it's just like everything else
they're just selling it oh they are i've
seen people selling toothpaste on the
street you know hate to
hate to shame someone for starting a
small business
but it's also the reason i can't get
toothpaste like i just get it on amazon
because you go there you're like i'm
gonna get toothpaste and then it's
locked behind you're like ugh i won't be
here all day that's the thing
it's the the the the added kind of
everything involves steps yeah you're
never at a in a good mood when you're at
the pharmacy yeah no
if someone created amazon
they bought one medical they should buy
all the pharmacies because they would
eliminate all of these steps the idea of
walking in and having because they don't
have enough workers there so there's
somebody who needs toothpaste i need my
spam
my spam suppositories and i have to sit
and wait while they go all over the
place and it's like it's impossible it
makes no sense spam by the way did come
from a monty python sketch well meaning
unwanted or unavoidable oh really that's
i thought that i thought that that skit
came off spamming oh interesting that
was i didn't need to know that
thank you
um feel free to comment either on the
spam or on the shoplifting or the
horribleness of your life stop it
sometimes i just love you um the thing
about the spam is some people really are
eating it they steal it because it's
instantly edible you know yeah and you
can always tell who went to jail for
stealing it because they're the ones who
like the taste of the prison food like
wow this is actually pretty good but
what i don't understand is why do they
put an anti-theft device on spam because
people who eat it regularly obviously
can't run very far you know what i mean
they're gonna be like two flights i hate
to tell you though have you seen
our law enforcement the standards on
weight has changed
it's amazing they've got it they got to
get they got to get the fitness program
back going because it's yeah and i love
our i love our police force they love me
we all get along well but there's like
maybe that's why the ice cream's locked
up yeah really yeah the ice cream has
been locked up for years in my
neighborhood which has kept a good 40
pounds off of me yeah when i'm drunk but
think about drunk wants and scream can't
get it yeah but think about this what
does it say about a democratic-run city
that our spam is locked up but our
criminals aren't like hello
and we should wrap up
it's trying to get us out
finally
finally jimmy says something that we can
actually write
after all that nonsense oh yes is
america out of sorts when we mix
politics with sports
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else